IT ALONE.
>> JOINING US NOW,
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
SECRETARY BUTTIGIEG, THANKS FOR
BEING WITH US.
I WANT TO GET TO THE
NEGOTIATIONS ON INFRASTRUCTURE
IN A MOMENT, BUT FIRST, IT'S
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND.
37 MILLION AMERICANS ARE
EXPECTED TO TRAVEL THIS WEEKEND.
MASKS ARE STILL REQUIRED ON
AIRPLANES AND PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION, DESPITE NEW CDC
GUIDANCE THAT VACCINATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE SAFE AND DO NOT
NEED TO WEARING A MASKS INDOORS
OR OUTDOORS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAYS
YOU WILL ALWAYS FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE.
WHAT SCIENCE IS THERE THAT SAYS
THAT A FULLY VACCINATED PERSON
NEEDS TO WEAR A MASK ON A PLANE
OR A TRAIN OR A BUS?
>> SO THE PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE
IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FOR
SITUATIONS LIKE PLANES AND
TRAINS.
PART OF IT HAS TO DO WITH UNIQUE
POSITIONS OF SPACE AND PART OF
IT WORKPLACE, AND OF COURSE,
THESE RULES AND REGULATIONS AND
THESE BODIES OF GUIDANCE ALWAYS
EVOLVE WITH THE WITNESS.
BOTTOM LINE IS, WE HAVE A SET OF
RULES IN PLACE TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE, AND I REALLY HOPE THAT
TRAVELERS WILL RESPECT FLIGHT
ATTENDANTS, BUS OPERATORS,
WORKERS.
ANYBODY WHO IS SIMPLY DOING
THEIR JOB TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
THINK ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE WHO WORK
IN TRAVEL AND TRANSPORTATION,
THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE BEEN
THROUGH OVER THE COURSE OF IT'S
LAST YEAR WITH THEIR JOBS IN
DOUBT, AND WITH A LOT OF
CHALLENGES ON THE JOB AND WITH A
RECORD NUMBER, AT LEAST, IN THE
RECENT MONTHS TRAVELING THIS
WEEKEND.
LET'S DO IT IN A WAY WE CAN BE
PROUD OF AND SHOW RESPECT FOR
ALL OF THOSE WORKERS WHO ARE
GETTING US TO WHERE WE NEED TO
BE.
>> TURN TO INFRASTRUCTURE
NEGOTIATIONS, JUST TO CATCH
EVERYONE UP.
PRESIDENT BIDEN STARTED AT $2.3
TRILLION IN HIS PROPOSAL.
REPUBLICANS STARTED AT ABOUT
$300 BILLION.
NOW PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS GONE
DOWN TO $1.7 TRILLION.
REPUBLICANS AT NEARLY $1
TRILLION OVER EIGHT YEARS.
YOU STILL WANT MORE MONEY FOR
RAIL AND YOU STILL CAN'T AGREE
ON HOW TO PAY FOR IT.
WHEN YOU AND I TALK OBD THE SHOW
SIX ECK WOOS AGO ABOUT IT YOU
SAID THE PRESIDENT WANTED MAJOR
ACTION BY MEMORIAL DAY.
SO WHAT'S NEXT?
IS THE WHITE HOUSE GOING TO MAKE
ANOTHER COUNTEROFFER?
WHAT'S THE PLAN?
>> YES.
SO, THIS WEEK CONGRESS IS OUT OF
WASHINGTON, BUT IT'S VERY MUCH
GOING TO BE A WORKWEEK FOR US
AND FOR THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
ARE ONGOING WITH CONGRESS.
BY THE TIME THAT THEY RETURN,
WHICH IS JUNE 7th, JUST A WEEK
FROM TOMORROW, WE NEED A CLEAR
DIRECTION.
YOU KNOW, CERTAIN ENCOURAGING TO
SEE THE HEALTHY CONVERSATIONS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED OVER THE LAST
DAYS AND WEEKS, BUT THE
PRESIDENT KEEPS SAYING INACTION
IS NOT AN OPTION AND TIME IS NOT
UNLIMITED HERE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE EXPECT US TO
DO SOMETHING.
THEY EXPECT US TO DELIVER AND
IT'S MY HOPE THAT THESE
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS REALLY
OVER THESE NEXT FEW DAYS WILL BE
PRODUCTIVE AND LEAD TO THAT
CLEAR DIRECTION.
>> SO THERE SEEMS TO BE A
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND, AGREED TO
WITH REPUBLICAN SENATORS, AND
WHAT HIS STAFF IS NOW SAYING.
KEY REPUBLICAN NEGOTIATOR SHELL
Y
MOORE REPUBLICAN FROM WEST
VIRGINIA SAYS AND OTHERS IN THE
ROOM WITH HER AGREE THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN SUGGESTED HE'S
WILLING TO SETTLE AROUND $1
TRILLION AND IT DIDN'T MATTER
WHETHER IT WAS $1 TRILLION OVER
FIVE OR EIGHT YEARS.
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS I
UNDERSTAND HOW TO PAY FOR IT,
TIMELINE, ET CETERA.
AS AN OVERALL PRINCIPLE, IS THAT
CORRECT?
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS WILLING TO
ACCEPT A $1 TRILLION PRICE TAG
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER TO HIM IF
IT'S OVER FIVE OR EIGHT YEARS?
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT'S
COUNTEROFFER WAS A $1.7 TRILLION
PACKAGE, AND, AGAIN, THAT
REPRESENTS COMING OFF OUR
ORIGINAL VIEW BY HALF A TRILLION
DOLLARS.
IT IS ENCOURAGING TO SEE
REPUBLICANS TALKING ABOUT
GETTING TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
$1 TRILLION.
OF COURSE, WHEN YOU START TRYING
TO MAKE IT APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARING WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
SPENT ANYWAY, LOOKING AT THE
CATEGORIES, THAT'S WHERE THE
DEVIL IS REALLY IN THE DETAILS.
THAT'S WHAT WE CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS WITH THEM.
I'LL SAY WE'VE BEEN IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS IN GOOD FAITH AND
THERE HAVE REALLY HEALTHY
NEGOTIATIONS OF THE KIND PEOPLE
STARTED TO WONDER WHETHER THAT'S
EVEN POSSIBLE IN WASHINGTON
ANYMORE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS IN
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS.
CATEGORIES LINE UP, NUMBERS LINE
UP.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
THING AND CAN WE GET TO AN
OVERLAP?
WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
DEFINITELY A LOT OF DIFFERENCE
IN OUR VIEWS BUT ENCOURAGING TO
SEE THE MOVEMENT.
>> JUST TO TRANSLATE FOR FOLKS
WHO AREN'T STAYING UP TO SPEED
ON EVERY DETAIL.
WHEN SECRETARY BUTTIGIEG TALKS
ABOUT THE MONEY THAT WOULD HAVE
BEENEN SPENT OTHERWISE, HE'S
TALKING ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRANSPORTATION MONEY AUTOMATIC
IN THE BUDGET, AND THE
SUGGESTION HAS BEEN MADE BY
DEMOCRATS THAT THE $1 TRILLION
OR ALMOST $1 TRILLION
COUNTERPROPOSAL REPUBLICANS MADE
OVER EIGHT YEARS IS REALLY ONLY
A COUPLE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
MORE THAN WHAT AUTOMATICALLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN SPENT.
RIGHT?
I'M HEARING YOU CORRECTLY?
I BELIEVE THAT THAT'S A CORRECT
ASSESSMENT.
SO MY QUESTION IS, DO YOU
THINK --
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
YES.
>> DOES THAT MEAN THAT THEY'RE
NEGOTIATING IN BAD FAITH?
>> NO.
THAT'S THE THING.
WE'VE BEEN VERY ABOVE BOARD WHEN
WE'RE IN THESE CONVERSATIONS.
CHARTS ARE OUT.
THE NUMBERS ARE THERE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS TO TALK ABOUT THE
SAME THING.
THE FACT THEY PHILOSOPHICALLY
SEEM TO AGREE THAT THE $1
TRILLION INVESTMENT IS THE KIND
OF THING WE NEED TO DO RIGHT NOW
IS ENCOURAGING BUT WE AREN'T
EXACTLY ALIGNED.
IN FACT, THERE'S A LOT OF
DAYLIGHT HERE.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THINGS WE
CONSIDER VERY IMPORTANT FROM
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE SPARKING
AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE REVOLUTION
AND THAT IT HAPPENS IN THE U.S.
WITH AMERICAN WORKERS ON
AMERICAN SOIL, TO THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMITMENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET RID OF 100% OF
LEAD PIPES IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE DIDN'T SEE AS MUCH OF THAT IN
THE COUNTERPROPOSAL.
AGAIN, THAT'S HOW A NEGOTIATION
WORKS.
EXACTLY THE THINGS WE'RE TALKING
THROUGH OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS
AND I EMPHASIZE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
BY THE TIME CONGRESS IS BACK IN
WASHINGTON, I THINK THOSE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND FRANKLY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND ALL OF
US IN THE ADMINISTRATION EXPECT
TO HAVE A CLEAR DIRECTION.
>> SO SOME DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS
WHO -- I'M NOT JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE BERNIE SANDERS TYPES
WHO ARE VERY SKEPTICAL OF
REPUBLICANS TO BEGIN WITH.
EVEN THOUGH SANDERS DOES HAVE A
RECORD OF BIPARTISAN WORK, BUT
SOME PEOPLE WHO MAKE A TRADITION
OF IT, WHO NORMALLY CUT DEALS,
THEY SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
BUTTIGIEG?
YOU'VE NEGOTIATED ENOUGH.
THE REPUBLICAN COUNTERPROPOSAL
ISN'T MUCH MORE THAN THE U.S.
WOULD HAVE SPENT ANYWAY.
YOU'RE WASTING YOUR TIME.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IT'S AN OLD EXPRESSION.
FISH OR CUT BAIT.
WE'RE GETTING TO THAT MOMENT.
>> WE HOPE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
REPUBLICANS, BUT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO LET THEM SAYING NO STAND IN
OUR WAY.
>> AT SOME POINT WE HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
>> CASEY, SCHUMER, DURBIN,
PEOPLE WHO GENERALLY WOULD BE IN
FAVOR OF NEGOTIATING.
ARE YOU BASICALLY SAYING THAT IN
THE NEXT WEEK IF THERE ISN'T AN
AGREEMENT, DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
TO GO IT ALONE?
>> I THINK WE ARE GETTING PRETTY
CLOSE TO A FISH OR CUT BAIT
MOMENT, BUT I'LL TELL THAW ON
THE FISHING SIDE OF THINGS, THE
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN HEALTHY.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
GOING ON.
AMONG MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO
HAVE COME FORWARD WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT IDEAS AND DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH A GROUP LED BY
THE SENATOR FROM WEST VIRGINIA.
SO WE BELIEVE IN THIS PROCESS
BUT ALSO VERY MUCH AGREE THIS
CAN'T GO ON FOREVER.
THE MEN PEOPLE WANT RESULTS.
WE ARE 13th PLACE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AS A COUNTRY NOW
AND PROBABLY HEADED IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
SEEING LOSSES TO THIS DAY.
NOT JUST THINGS YOU COUNT UP IN
INDUSTRY GROUP REPORTS OF THE
BILLIONS LOST WHEN WE HAVE PORT
BACKUPS, JUT INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES
PAYING HUNDREDS OF BUCKS A YEAR
IN THE SO-CALLED POTHOLE TAX.
INVISIBLE COST OF WEAR AND TEAR
ON OUR VEHICLES WHEN ROADS
AREN'T IN GOOD SHAPE.
THIS CAN'T GO ON IN TERMS OF
CONDITION OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE,
THEREFORE, NEGOTIATIONS CAN'T GO
ON FOREVER EITHER.
>> YOU'VE A VETERAN, BEFORE YOU
GO, SERVED AS AN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER.
I KNOW THERE'S SOMETHING YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THIS MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, FOR MEMORIAL DAY, WHEN
YOU SERVE, OF COURSE, YOU THINK
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T MAKE IT
BACK FROM A DEPLOYMENT.
ALSO THINKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
CAME BACK SEEMINGLY WHOLE FROM A
DEPLOYMENT WHO WE LOST YEARS
AFTER THEY RETURNED, AND IT'S A
REMINDER THAT YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT SOMEBODY'S UP AGAINST THAT,
YOU KNOW, MENTAL HEALTH
STRUGGLES ARE REAL AND NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED, AND THAT IT'S
NEVER A BAD TIME TO CHECK ON
SOMEBODY YOU SERVED WITH OR TO
CHECK ON SOMEBODY YOU CARE
ABOUT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SECRETAR